good night it's a no and for simon
cowell his latest know is two-face
fillers that's a big deal simon reveals
to uk outlet the sun he saw a photo of
himself prior to his botox injection
days
and admits he didn't recognize himself
he says quote there was a stage where i
might have gone a bit too far
the former american idol judge goes on
to explain he looked quote like
something out of a horror film that's
what it looked like to me and that
horror made his eight-year-old son eric
hysterical simon says he since said
goodbye to his face fillers
well you just know when the time's right
and while simon is giving his face a bit
of a break he's doing the same for his
body too fans may remember the america's
got talent judge broke his back in
august of 2020 while testing out an
electric bike at his home in malibu fast
forward to 2022 and another biking
accident this time simon breaking his
arm it was that quick despite the
setbacks for simon the music mogul
opened up to e.t in february about
having fun with his arm cast
man it's good to see you in one piece i
mean kinda no
you look good too a lot better than i
thought i was like oh is that arm going
to be up or what's going to be going on
with it
nice
now you can choose the color you want so
it was eric's birthday a couple of days
ago so i said i've got to get a new one
any any color requests
uh purple with sparkles while the 62
year old is focused on healing he's got
a wedding coming up i'm happy right now
et confirmed he popped the question to
his longtime love lauren silverman over
the holidays while vacationing in
barbados you're okay are you
are you okay you're in one piece let me
just let me make sure let me check that
check i haven't broken another bone
how how are you feeling i'm pretty good
and you look great i feel absolutely
good yeah
are you doing wedding planning how's
that going and what how much will eric
be important you know we discussed this
yeah we talked about it yeah you'll do
my bachelor party
it's going to be a party y'all vegas
this would be the perfect place
[Music]
you